prior to coming to the GSB I worked for
a health care not for profit on a
campaign to spread best practices in US
hospitals I went to Harvard undergrad
graduating 03 and worked in finance for
four years most recently in an
investment management so I worked for a
firm that bought commercial and
multi-family large multifamily projects
for institutional investors I was
working for an airline in Central
America and I was in there in as part of
their strategic development group I was
working in New York for a book
publishing company so I came from the
media world and I worked as an editor
for a couple of years and then was in
the marketing department there I was a
legislative advocate and a campaign
manager for the natural resources
defense council in Washington DC so I
worked on enacting federal energy policy
and climate policy to advanced clean
energy in the United States and to
establish regulations to govern
greenhouse gas emissions I worked as a
consultant at the boston consulting
group in dallas texas so I come from a
very non-traditional background before
coming here in September I've been
living in China and working there for
six years so i loved what i was doing in
Asia but I definitely felt like I didn't
have a deep enough business background
the fundamentals I not a finance guy not
an accounting guy I had real life
experience but there are a lot of
fundamentals that I would have helped me
sort of think bigger picture about what
I was doing prior to coming to the GSP i
was working in london in finance and
investment banking at citigroup i am a
mechanical engineer that's what I
studied before coming to school then I
work in a internet startup and the 99
boom it didn't work so I then join a
public relations firm as a marketing
sales a marketing manager and then I
took a CEO position and the public
relations firm in chile before coming to
GSP I was a relationship manager for
wachovia bank and I worked down a South
Florida and I covered the Miami area so
I came from China with boring Beijing
and I went to university of illinois for
PhD a mechanic and jury I was working in
Brazil for a large conglomerate there in
mainly corporate finance and mergers and
acquisitions I worked at rosetta stone
which is this language learning software
company and while I was there we helped
grow it 10 times and then sold the
business to private equity and it was a
great operational role I managed finance
and then 40 years managed product
development and you know it's kind of
funny actually coming to the business
school from a small company background I
think most people are trying to leave
the business school and go into a small
company and I was coming from a small
company and now I'm going into
consulting so I think I'm kind of doing
the reverse path and most people